leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems okay
listen up
folks we have a security situation here
as you know
when we reach a location i will be
conducting a security sweep
also from now on we'll be using code
names you can address me
as eagle one and codename been there
done that
april is currently doing that donna is
it happened once in a dream chris code
name if i had to pick a dude
ben is eagle two oh thank god
i can't believe we're at hogwarts no
that's
buckingham palace hogwarts is fictional
do you know that it's important to me
that you know that
andy are you okay oh i'm fine it's just
that
life is pointless and nothing matters
and i'm always tired also i can't sleep
i'm overeating
none of my old hobbies interest me ever
since andy failed the police academy
exam
his self-esteem has hit rock bottom he's
always sad and sweaty
he's usually happy and sweaty
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster i had to also i had a
banana on the way over here
sorry i get why you don't want anyone to
know about duke silver and you don't
have to worry
your secret is safe with me to even it
out
i'm gonna tell you all of my secrets oh
no that's
not necessary i once forgot to brush my
teeth for five weeks
i didn't actually sell my last car i
just forgot where i parked it i don't
know who al gore is and at this point
i'm too afraid to ask
when they say two percent milk i don't
know what the other 98
is when i was a baby my head was so big
scientists did experiments on me
i once threw beer at a swan and then it
attacked my niece rebecca
that'll do andrew go go go go go go go
yes oh my god that's so hot that was
horrible
oh i'm going to die i'm so tired
everything hurts running is impossible
what are you doing tom now is not the
time for criticism
how did he do and he finished his two
mile run in 29 minutes and 43 seconds
no i'm never gonna be a cop
i'm gonna have to be a robber so the
only thing you did was stop drinking
beer
yeah i lost 50 pounds in one month how
much
beer were you drinking i know right
probably too much
did you hit your head no
oh yes technically i did smash my head
area
into the wall area yeah he was hanging
up his gold record
oh my god are you okay yeah i'm good
point is i have a gold record e
h four m potato
shape coffee mug shape smudge
smudge middle finger smudge the rest are
all smudges oh my god you drove us here
we made like 100 million doctor's
appointments for ourselves in one week
after this we won't have to go to the
doctor for like 10 years
because we're smart well you definitely
need glasses
no he's not getting glasses i like his
face the way it is if you get glasses
i'll divorce you
well you heard her doc too handsome for
glasses no offense
here's your bill oh yeah we need that
i've got the free medicine card
uh there's a 500 deductible for dental
procedures
oh i think uh you're wrong we have the
insurance thing
i believe we're covered it's still five
hundred dollars
let's see here oh because
you know what dina dash out of the way
yeah oh
my god ambulance a different ambulance
the one i ran into
i've been staring at this board for days
so close to putting it together there's
got to be something we missed
let's go over this again the video
shows that the pie came from a high
angle
so it would have hit your face
like this don't close your eyes
no no it actually was from up higher
is that about right yeah good clean
yourself up
let's do this again so i made my desk
out of silver m
m's but they do not make silver m m's so
i spray painted them
okay those are poisonous so no one eat
them yeah duh
go throw up i didn't eat any go throw up
what should we do tonight i don't know
let's figure we'll just order some pizza
you watch me play xbox and then i can
watch you make some prank phone calls we
get hammered
make out we do that every night it's
because repetition
is the key to a good marriage let's do
something weird
come on it could be the last night on
earth we could do something off my
bucket list
you have a bucket list catch when you
any touchdown at the super bowl
make the most amazing grilled cheese
sandwich ever win the lottery
ride a unicycle invent something i'd
like to remake the movie kazam with
shaquille o'neal where he plays a genie
and i'd like to get it right
go skydiving outrun a hippo all right
well this is what we're doing tonight
wait which one
this one 800 900 1 000.
and how much is left in the bank account
18
and four cents whoa still a lot left
over okay
you wanted to hold a thousand dollars
cash in your hands
that's super disappointing
998 999 1000
yes now this is what i imagined
have you ever seen this much cash in
your entire life
i just handed it to you nickels
i want nickels a billion nickels no andy
[Music]
so
it's so much more beautiful than i could
have ever even imagined
yeah trying to find a way to be annoyed
by it but
coming up empty thank you so much
i never would have ever done this
without you
thank you
where's all the faces hit the presidents
it's 5 000 times better than a candle in
the wind
this song is called 5 000
candles in the
up in wind heaven here's the thing
you trade your legs for angels
wings and once we've
[Music]
[Music]
master
[Music]
[Applause]
you